hi guys this is Luca from Luca
repair.com and today I'm going to talk
with Matt from m.i.a
hi Matt hey guys yeah my name is Matt I
have a youtube channel called Matt verse
Japan where I talk about my experience
learning Japanese and how I recommend
people to go about learning other
languages and it's an honor to be here
fantastic and what does m.i.a stand for
yeah so m.i.a stands for mass immersion
approach it's a comprehensive approach
to acquiring foreign languages that was
created by myself and my friend Yoga
fantastic so we ready to go I prepared a
list of questions for formats probably
some of my audience some somebody
already knows Matt who speaks very
fluent Japanese I've seen your interview
with Steve Kaufman was another linguist
and polyglot and I have a you know
compared to you I have a smattering of
Japanese but I could definitely tell
your Japanese was sounded and was
fantastic so cute so let's get to it the
first question here is what were your
initial reasons for learning Japanese
did they stay the same over time or have
they changed as you've grown with the
language yeah so I very first became
interested in Japanese when I was a
freshman in high school when I was in
ninth grade and up until that point I
had no interest in learning foreign
languages in fact I was failing my
Spanish class that I was required to
take and really if you would ask me at
the time why did I one day become so
interested in Japanese I don't think I
would have been able to give you a good
answer I was just watching Japanese
anime and in a way it was love at first
sight as soon as I started listening to
the language there was just something
that sounded so elegant about it and
something that just really drew me in
and so in a way there was no real good
logical reason and in hindsight you know
now that it's been almost ten years
since I initially started learning
Japanese I've done a kind of some
psychoanalysis on my old self and I
think there was a little bit of it being
attracted to the you know how exotic
Japan seemed and even some wanting to
escape my own culture but I don't know
how where I was at the time but anyway
yeah as time went on I definitely kind
of grew
out of my initial motivations and it
really just became a matter of just
feeling like at a certain point Japanese
culture and the Japanese language had
become a part of me and it just felt
natural for me to continue to study and
want to improve and once I really felt
that Japanese was going to continue to
be a part of my life going forward then
I knew I had to get really good because
I was gonna be spending a lot of time
with it so I wanted to you know be able
to be really functional in it fantastic
and do you think that you know I'm just
gonna also I have a list of questions
but I'm also gonna improvise because
more and more things come to my mind
were speaking so do you think the Jacke
learning Japanese to the level you have
learned Japanese has changed you as a
person and the way you see the world
because I had a friend of mine for
example he's Italian he lived in Japan
for 10 years and he acts like a Japanese
a time but he is he shows this kind of
kindness that sometimes we Westerners
have forgotten not it's not just a
matter of kindness but he shows a number
of traits that is really surprising it
is as if Japanese had changed him inside
it's not just like I he speaks for
another language so did something like
that happen to you as well yeah I think
it definitely has I mean I've spent so
much of my adult life interacting with
Japanese and with Japanese people that
yeah in a way I think it's a huge part
of me it's a huge part of the way I see
the world and of course there's a lot of
typical Japanese traits and pieces of
Japanese culture that I think I've
absorbed but more than anything else I
think just having the contrast of how
different cultural different cultures
can be has really gave given me a more
experiential understanding of cultural
relativity and that has totally changed
the way I see my own culture because I
understand a lot of the ways that we
interact within our culture and a lot of
the norms and beliefs they don't have to
be that way in a way that they might
even be arbitrary and so I think that is
a huge asset that I have and I don't
think I would have been able to ever
have this perspective without having an
experiential access point to a totally
different culture you also speak other
languages or do you want to learn other
languages yeah I've been studying
Chinese like Mandarin Chinese
on and off for a while and I really want
to take it further but I think I struck
just because I've spent so long being
pretty comfortable with Japanese it's
really hard to put myself back in the
back in the shoes of a beginner and and
there's also parts of me that still want
to improve my Japanese even more I feel
like it's it's never the process is
never completed so but it is still
definitely something I'm hoping to take
further in the future fantastic well
they say for example that Mandarin is
Mandarin Chinese is one of the most of
the language in the world I think the
Japanese is pretty tough itself I didn't
in my own experience I didn't find
Mandarin Chinese to be that difficult
truth be told there are difficulties in
learning Asian languages or some late
Asian languages for example Mandarin
Chinese has tones that are difficult to
learn but I think the syntax and the way
you formulate inform sentences and
thoughts is not as complicated for for a
westerner so or a person who speaks
English or French or Italian because
Japanese is a completely different
structure not just it's not just a
matter of structure it's a way you form
thoughts that is different that's that
stuff so I'm always in awe of people who
speak Japanese fluently okay on to the
next question when you started learning
Japanese how and why did you settle on
immersion as opposed to any of the other
popular language learning methods did
you try something else first and then
you decided to go for immersion yeah
well so actually for the first two years
that I was studying Japanese I was
taking a very typical traditional
language learning approach of just
taking classes at my high school and
going through normal text books and
maybe watching a few how to learn
Japanese YouTube videos and so at the
time I wasn't thinking very deeply about
the process of learning a language or
thinking about methodology or anything
it was kind of just like oh you want to
learn something you go to school
because that was what my told my culture
had taught me and I went to Japanese
class at my high school I transferred
into the the Japanese I was lucky about
my high school had Japanese classes and
so I transferred out of Spanish into
Japanese halfway through the semester
through begging the teacher to let me
and over the that summer I even went to
my local community college and took the
second year's
worth of Japanese on my own and then
when I came back on my second year of
high school I was taking the third year
and I was doing the best in my class
because I studied the most because I
loved it so much and I found the classes
very fun actually all those a lot of
people really don't enjoy classes but at
the end of two years of studying
Japanese in this traditional way I
really didn't have very much to show for
it I couldn't understand natural
Japanese conversation or Japanese TV
shows I could only express myself by
thinking in English and taking a lot of
time to translate each of my thoughts
into unnatural Japanese and so I didn't
really wasn't really achieving the
results that I wanted and then I came
across this blog called all Japanese all
the time which was I've heard of it yes
yeah I was created by a by this guy
named katsu moto who claimed to reach a
very impressive level of Japanese in
just 18 months through totally immersing
himself in the language even though he
was living outside of the country he was
just going to college in the United
States but he used the internet and mp3
players and things like this to just
totally immerse himself in Japanese and
he kind of wrote about his methodology
and as soon as I read it it made perfect
sense to me because he kind of painted
this picture that you know when you
think about the way that we learn our
native language we don't study grammar
or memorize vocabulary we just get
exposed to it for thousands and tens of
thousands of hours and first we learn
how to understand the language and then
we learn to speak through mimicking and
so we kind of painted this picture that
adults have this assumption that it's
impossible to learn the way that
children do but really we don't have any
evidence for this assumption being true
because we don't actually give it a shot
we don't actually try listening for
thousands of hours we try it for like a
couple hundred hours and then just
conclude that it doesn't work and so
this totally made sense to me and I also
had the actual evidence that it worked
because there was a video of caught
samoto speaking Japanese and I showed it
to some Japanese friends and they
verified that he sounded almost like a
native speaker and so that was enough
kind of motivation for me to just give
it a shot and although in hindsight now
my views on language learning have
differed quite a bit from katsu moto and
I don't think that ultimately it's as
simple as simply immerse yourself in the
language and you'll magically become
perfect but definitely I think immersion
is the key to reaching really high
levels and yeah really really lucky I
stumbled upon that site when I did so
interesting you said that your your
vision now differs a little bit in which
sense what what changed what are the
realizations that you have you know
you've come to when it comes to learning
acquiring secondly yeah so I would say
that fundamentally if you read the
original all Japanese all the time
website constant mode is basically
presenting this idea that when it comes
to language learning the brain of an
adult is completely equivalent to the
brain of a child so if you completely
replicate a child's process you will
achieve a child's results and ultimately
I don't think this is true I think that
as you get older your ability to acquire
a language and completely through
immersion does decline a little bit and
this is mainly due to your brain
optimizing itself to the languages that
you already know so you know one easy
example is that between ages of you know
six months and ten months old babies
lose the ability to hear sounds that
don't exist in their native language now
you might think of this as kind of the
process of the brain kind of downgrading
itself or losing previous ability but I
think of it as the brain upgrading
itself because by losing the ability to
hear sounds that it doesn't need to hear
it becomes more adept at hearing the
sounds that are relevant to it so it's
just optimizing itself learning to
ignore things that it has deemed
irrelevant and so by the time you become
an adult you reach you know 15 years of
age or more your brain has trained
itself to ignore lots of different
things and assume that language works
whatever way it does in your native
language and you have to kind of
overcome that so in a way it's kind of
like if you are a baby you're starting
off with a clean slate a slate of paper
and you're folding it into like an
origami crane but as an adult you have
to unfold that piece of paper and now
you're trying to make something entirely
new how to origami like let's say a frog
out of this paper that already has all
these creases in it and so of course all
the creases from the the crane are gonna
be kind of pulling you in different
directions and it takes a lot of
practice in certain areas to overcome
that and
make your brain function in an entirely
different way and so I think that like
for example I think this was on on some
of the questions you sent me a little
later on but it's kind of relevant now I
think that one of the things that
immersion won't necessarily be a fix-all
for it are aspects of a foreign language
that differ from your native language
but also aren't completely necessary for
communicating in that language so for
example for a lot of people who learn
English as a Second Language they might
struggle with things like articles and I
think the reason for this is that they
don't have the type of articles that we
have in English in their native language
but also you can kind of get away with
ignoring articles both when you're
listening and when you're speaking and
it won't necessarily be an impediment to
communication so in a way the brain
starts off from this position of
assuming that articles aren't a thing
because that's what the conclusion it
came to you through its native language
and then there's nothing to really tip
the brain off that this assumption is
false because no nothing no errors seem
to pop up with it just ignoring these
articles whereas for other aspects of
the language like for example word order
in Japanese word or an order in Japanese
it's completely different than word
order in English but if your brain
doesn't figure out that word order is
different in this language you really
aren't gonna get anywhere so it's kind
of like you have the brain has this
impetus to uproot its old assumptions
and that's why I think just through
immersion you can get used to the
Japanese grammar and you can get used to
how the particles work and things like
that and so I think it's ultimately a
matter of learning everything you can
naturally through immersion and then
looking at what little bits and pieces
did your brain miss and maybe studying
up on those a bit and then training your
brain to notice those things when you
immerse in the language so if I got it
right what you're saying is that if you
immerse yourself to the language a
language that is very different from
yours for example like Japanese in
English immersion in and of itself does
not suffice it's not sufficient in order
to understand the nitty-gritties or the
nooks and crannies of the language is
that correct meaning yeah if you want to
reach perfection yeah of course of
course we're that like me you want to
speak languages really well so is not
matter of speaking language I think
there's a there's a point where we can
speak the language fluently you can get
your point across you can live you can
function within a society but another
thing is speaking like an almost like a
native and getting all the cultural
references in the small nuances that's
that's a different ballgame that's
that's a different world
okay very good so one other point to
make on that though you know I do just
like you said I definitely think that
immersion alone if you're just sitting
and getting exposure it can it's going
to take you to a level where you're
pretty comfortable but not to the level
of where you're functioning just like a
native is and that's when I think more
active study comes in and more active
practice but ultimately I don't think
it's a matter of like for example with
articles in English I don't think it's a
matter of memorizing the rules of how to
use articles and practicing applying
those rules those rules in real time I
think it's more a matter of learning
about those articles and kind of
analyzing what your natural brain what
your unconscious mind missed and then
training yourself to notice that in your
immersion so that you can absorb it more
naturally and build a more intuitive
understanding of it and once you have
that intuitive understanding it will be
more natural for you to to be able to
produce it yourself I got more and more
questions popping up in my mind okay I
got two questions in this regard the
first one is if you say if you think
that immersion by itself is not
sufficient to learn the donítí greedy's
of the language and to speak really well
and if cut samoto applied this technique
and he immersed himself how did he get
to the level where it could speak almost
like a native did he also maybe he
didn't tell anybody else but maybe he
did some more I don't know active
training or trying to
I don't know rack his rein some grammar
I don't I have heard of katsumata but I
don't know I don't know how this
methodology yes
so I was just curious as to yeah how you
got there were where he got okay so one
thing that for myself was and this is
also kind of related to a question you
asked you later on but so for me one uh
I was spending most of my Japanese
learning career under the assumption
that if I just got enough immersion I
would eventually reach perfection that
was the paradigm on I was where
and that worked well for a lot of things
but one of the biggest things that my
brain just totally missed and I didn't
get until I started studying it more
consciously was what's called pitch
accent in Japanese so context in
Japanese yeah yeah please explain it I
love it yeah so it's a it's kind of
similar to tones and Mandarin Chinese
except instead of functioning on a per
syllable basis they're functioning on a
per word basis so basically every word
in Japanese has a pitch accent and which
is basically the the ups and the rises
and falls in pitch that you have to
pronounce that word with and if you get
that wrong it can either change the the
meaning of the word entirely or it can
just make it sound kind of funny it's a
lot like stress accent in English how
you know we say tomorrow not tomorrow
and if my Apple of a word the changes
according to the so for example if you
say Hashi that can be in bridge and if
you say Hashi that means chopsticks or
um it means candy and um it means rain
but if I'm not wrong you also have the
gap for example if you're introducing
her how she got how's she so you have
yes yeah there's actually yeah three so
if you add a particle onto it then you
have like for example ha see this would
mean the it's the edge of something ha
see this means it's a bridge and ha she
this means it's chopsticks right so if
you I think you talked about about this
in the other interview that he made with
Steve Kaufman do you think that you
could reach a native like japonais t'v
like pronunciation in Japanese without
delving into this without understanding
without being conscious of the so called
pitch accent so truth be told Japanese
kids never know about yes maybe learn
about pitch accent maybe in linguistics
if they attend linguistic lectures later
so they don't need to know about that
but do you think that as an adult
learning a second language learning
Japanese as a second language you need
to know that in order to speak like a
native I'm talking men see Asian wise
okay yeah I mean I think that for most
people they do need to study it in order
to actually go on to acquire it and I
didn't want this to be true for the
longest time but if you look
the empirical data it seems to be the
case I studied Japanese for 5 years I
got very fluent I could easily express
myself but I totally was missing out on
pitch accent like if you listen to old
recordings of me it's not just that I
pronounce words consistently with the
wrong pitch accent it's that every time
I'd say a word I'd say it with a
different pitch accent which tells me
that my brain was lacking an entire
concept that there might even be a
connection between pitch and lexical
meaning so that whole concept was gone
and when I listened to other English
speakers or other European people who've
reached a very high level of fluency in
Japanese nine times out of ten they are
just like me and they completely lack
the concept of pitch accent now the
interesting thing is a lot of Chinese
people who reach a high level of
Japanese do seem to naturally acquire
pitch accent even without consciously
studying it and this kind of makes sense
because their brain is already
predisposed to the idea that there might
be a connection between changes in pitch
and lexical meaning because they have
tones in in Chinese so that kind of goes
back to what I was talking about a few
minutes ago about how when you learn
English your brain basically develops
the assumption that Lex that pitch
doesn't affect lexical meaning meaning
changes the meanings of words all it
only affects the kind of emotionality of
the sentence so you know if I say wait
that's you or like oh that's you you
know that's changes in pitch it's
changing the meaning but it's not
changing the meaning of the individual
words sure so your brain just learns to
say oh I guess there's no such thing as
connections between lexical meaning and
pitch and so it just stops looking for
it because looking for something that's
not there as a waste of time then you go
to Japanese you carry over this
assumption and the thing is unlike tones
in Chinese you can get away with
ignoring pitch accent in Japanese
because even if you mess up the pitch
accents of words you can still Japanese
people most of the time can still infer
what words are trying to say from the
context and also there's different
dialects of Japanese that have different
pitch accents so Japanese people have
some experience understanding different
ways of pronouncing words but you're
still gonna sound very funny to them so
I think that's the thing is like I would
be pronouncing words at the wrong pitch
accent and I'd get away with it Japanese
people would very rarely point it out to
me because they're really nice when it
comes to for
yes yeah you denied the others you know
it was like they don't want to correct
you um yeah and and so going back to you
asked about Casa moto so when if you
watch those old videos across somewhat
as being Japanese he messes up pitch
accent fairly often like multiple times
a minute but the thing is Japanese
people are so nice when they're giving
feedback that they exaggerate like five
levels above where you really are so if
you say if you know like five words and
Japanese and you just do a basic self
introduction they go oh wow you're so
good at Japanese like I'm impressed
and when you are actually fluent they
say oh wow you're better at Japanese
than Japanese people but it's not true
it's just their their culture and their
way of complimenting you what they
really mean is yeah you're pretty good
absolutely okay so if you--if you got
this feedback from the Japanese which
was not very which is great for your ego
maybe but not for your Japanese how did
you go back and fixed your accents now
before you ask before you reply to that
question I want to say that to me when
kids in general learn their own native
language they learn implicitly that is
they get massive exposure to the
language and their brain figures out
different patterns not just grammar
patterns but also obviously
pronunciation / intonation patterns they
do it implicitly and adults or adults
they learn the language most of the time
at school for example in the traditional
system they learn the language
explicitly this goes for grammar
patterns as well as pronunciation
patterns I don't know about the United
States but in Italy and in Europe I've
never heard of a specific training in
pronunciation I don't know of any
teacher in school apart maybe from some
link I don't know some some classes at
university that focuses on a pragmatical
straightforward training in
pronunciation because that's possible
this is what I do my job is to help
people you know get better and
pronouncing not just the language itself
the acquisition of the language itself
but also the pronunciation and
intonation of various languages and my
there's two key points here do you the
first do you think that it's possible
for a non-native so for a foreigner to
acquire native pronunciation in a
language for example in Japanese and the
second ones
cific to your to your case is since I
heard you I'm not a Japanese but I can
tell you that your accent is on point
that is you have worked on your accent
how did you go back and learn or fixed
the inaccuracies you want to call it
that of your pitch accent and your
intonation in Japanese yeah so do I
think it's possible to achieve it a
fully native accent I mean I'm not gonna
say anything's impossible but I think
it's kind of like an easy diminishing
rate yeah yeah yeah I think there's
diminishing returns when it comes to
trying to get closer and closer to
someone who was born and raised speaking
a certain language and so I think with
efficient practice and training you can
get very very close and achieve a really
great accent without too much work or
too much effort and then after that
certain point when it really comes to
reaching a hundred percent native I
think that's when more natural talent
kind of comes in a little bit some
people just have more of an affinity for
mimicking sounds and also yeah there's
just a lot of a lot of practice but that
comes in and so for for myself with
Japanese so what are you done we want to
know we want to yes well one of the
things that I've noticed is that people
who who it's really important to them to
have good pronunciation in whatever
language of studying tend to have good
pronunciation and people who tend to not
really care that much if they have a
strong foreign accent they tend to have
strong foreign accents and this is
separate from any conscious work they do
so I kind of feel that it's like your
your unconscious mind it's kind of in in
sync with your value system and so if
you naturally value having good
pronunciation and sounding like the
people who you're trying to mimic then
it's just gonna naturally be more
attentive to the language whenever
you're talking to native speakers are
listening and it's naturally gonna
absorb more more of it and then you're
gonna be able to produce more of it
whereas if you don't care about it then
your brains gonna be efficient it's it's
not gonna waste any energy on something
that isn't important to you and so for a
start like for me I really want it to
sound Japanese and so I think whenever I
was listening to Japanese that was part
of my mind that was kind of just honed
in on the sounds and
I really get well how are they
pronouncing certain things and I think
this is why I didn't really put that
much conscious effort into say like
perfecting my vowels or consonants that
was something that it seemed to be that
after I did get a lot of exposure to
Japanese that once I started speaking I
started to develop that pretty naturally
and I think a part of this is that
through spending so many hours listening
to Japanese and listening very
attentively I started to build an
intuition for what it's supposed to
sound like so that when I started
speaking whenever my vowels or my
constant continents would deviate from
what I understood was supposed to sound
like it would be like a bell would go
off in my head a bit that didn't sound
right that sounded weird and so I could
naturally kind of guide myself to a more
native-like pronunciation of the vows
and the consonants because I knew when
it sounded right now I don't think that
my intuition for Japanese pronunciation
is the to the same level as a native
speaker I think maybe it's like 95% of
the way there so there's a certain level
where my vowels and consonants might
sound 100% perfect to me but to a native
speaker it might be like something
sounds a little bit funny and this is
where I think it's kind of like a
barrier that you hit up against that
it's really hard to kind of surpass but
in a way it's good enough because I I
can sound very close acting sound to the
point where on the phone they might not
assume that I'm a foreigner if they
didn't already know they would they
would have to talk to me for a while
before they start to wonder wait is
something off and I think most people
would say that's good enough
but with pitch accent in particular this
was something that yeah it just went
over my head and so what my process
ended up being was well so how I even
realized I was missing this was that I
would try to get feedback for my
Japanese friends and I'd say like if you
this was before I ever study pitch
accent I said if you just heard my voice
on the phone would you be able to tell
that I wasn't Japanese and they would
say well yeah I think so
and I would say so what about my
Japanese gives it away that I'm not a
native speaker and what they would say
is oh your intonation sounds weird right
and so for a while I didn't really even
know what that meant because it turns
out the Japanese people they are not
taught anything about pitch accent in
school and so they really have no
conscious conception of what pitch
accent is how it's different from
intonation and so on and so most of the
time they've just call
Jaxson intonation and so and I was like
what do you mean my intonation is weird
how am I supposed to go about fixing
that I didn't even know what it meant
but a while after a while I kind of
realized oh they're talking about pitch
accent and I started studying up about
it and learning about how the pitch
accent system works because I didn't
even know how many patterns there were
or whatever it'd be like if you're
learning Mandarin Chinese and you don't
know how many tones exist in the
language that was like basically where I
was and so I learned about the basic
pitch accent system and at first I
couldn't even really hear it when I
would listen to Japanese but I started
listening for it and over time I got
better and better at hearing it and I
learned more more the rules and things
like that and I just started to pay
attention to the pitch whenever I would
listen to Japanese I would just be
trying to follow along and hear all the
Rises and all the Falls and after a
while it started to become so natural to
me I couldn't even remember imagine what
it'd be like to not hear that and it got
to the point that like when I would
watch videos of myself speaking Japanese
I could started to hear where he was off
it was like oh no that's not it doesn't
go down there it's supposed to to go up
there and things like that and so
through consciously paying lots of
attention to how it's done the right way
I started to build more of an intuition
throughout supposed to sound and then I
could do that same thing where I would
speak and I would be able to notice
myself where I was wrong so that I could
you know bring myself back on track and
through lots of practice I was able to
get a lot better at it now I'm
definitely still far from perfect I
don't actually actively practice that
much because I live in the United States
and and things like that but I still
feel like I could like 100% perfection I
think is really difficult but I could
probably get to like I don't know 95%
accuracy if I just practice for a half
an hour a day for a few weeks I could
get a lot better at it right um so what
are your what you're saying is that if I
if I got a ride is that you didn't do
any specific deliberate practice or
deliberate training but you developed a
consciousness some kind of awareness by
delving into how the pitch accent works
and then based on that your mind started
to pick up things that it would not be
cup that would it not understand because
without some explanations so are you
suggesting for example - I mean I'm
exactly on the same wavelength I'm a
perfection
as I like pronunciation some people
don't care some people just want to talk
and and and want to have decent
pronunciation want to be comprehensible
but do you think that for an adult it is
important to be it I don't know they
want to they want to learn fringe they
want to learn another language is
important is important to do some
trained some sort of training or some
sort of research into pronunciation /
intonation if they want to get really
good so if someone comes and says oh man
it doesn't matter I'm just gonna listen
to a lot of French and then I'm gonna
pick up the accent because that's how
some people did it you know what would
you suggest what would you say yeah I'd
say well hey some people can maybe just
listen to French and end up with the
perfect axis but that's maybe one out of
ten went out of a hundred people read on
that being you if it's really important
to you and assuming that you're not one
of those really naturally gifted people
then yeah I think studying about how the
pronunciation system works that how the
phonetic system works is really valuable
but not necessarily because that's going
to directly translate into a better
ability to speak it probably will to a
degree but the true value of it is it's
going to help you pay attention to the
right things and through paying
attention of the right things
that's what's gonna really lead to make
all the difference okay so I did do some
conscious study with pitch accent but it
was conscious study that allowed me to
know what to pay attention to because if
I was just gonna say okay I'm gonna pay
attention a pitch and just try to notice
whatever I could that would have been a
lot less efficient than knowing okay
it's supposed to go down here did it go
down there like oh it's supposed to go
up here oh this is what the uprise
actually sounds like and so I think yeah
conscious study is useful to the extent
that it helps you hone in on what to pay
attention to in native speech in this
regard to more things come to my mind
the your experience for Japanese is very
similar my experience with Swedish when
I posted my first youtube video in 2008
and eight I was convinced that my
pronunciation / intonation and
intonation were great and Swedish only
to discover that a lot of people are not
complaining but they were just saying
your your intonation is off your
pronunciation is off and then much to my
dismay I might add I have I found out
that Swedish is a semi or semi tonal
language that is you know they have
it's it's not exactly like Mandarin
Chinese but it has it has very specific
features that make the intonation very
peculiar I had completely skipped that I
didn't even I remember I had this this
book I started with I just didn't care I
thought you know what I'm just good at
picking up sound so I'm just gonna it's
gonna happen and then I figured out the
mistake the huge mistake that I've made
because before some languages maybe
Spanish or French the older languages
they had learned so far up to that point
were not didn't have this feature and
the first moment that you stumble upon a
language it has a different completely
different from either be it fanatic or
grammatical feature that's where some
deliberate training and some awareness
is important because your brain is
accustomed and and you know used to
there's certain patterns and when it
sees a new pattern it just gets lost and
you have to give it a little that's
that's where I think kids and adults are
different I don't think that adults are
any worse or any better than kids I just
think they learn differently and so
since they have different circuitry you
have to you can leverage certain
strengths of our system or of our brain
that kids don't have and and the other
way around
so I anyway just I completely agree with
you Lee yeah and the another question I
had for you what has speaking like
almost like a Navy brought to your life
meaning some people might say Matt what
do you spend why don't you invest so
much time into speaking or sounding like
a native what's what's what's the catch
what should the return of investment you
know what what what impact has it had
had on your life on your interactions on
your social life on your on your on your
inner world - yeah well I found that as
my pronunciation improved the way that
Japanese people reacted to me speaking
noticeably changed and this might differ
depending on what language you're
studying but in Japanese in particular
Japanese people aren't very accustomed
to interacting with foreign speakers of
Japanese that or at least they're not
accustomed to interacting with foreign
speakers who are at a high level you
know many Japanese people have never
really talked to a foreigner in Japanese
and had an in-depth conversation and
there's kind of this assumption that
they aren't gonna understand their
culture or they're not going to really
understand enough for their language to
have
have a meaningful discussion and so for
me it's really the pronunciation that
gives that first impression to them and
so when they hear me speak Japanese now
they I think to a degree get the sense
of like oh they're like me I can speak
to them normally I don't have to censor
myself and try to dumb down my language
they'll understand me or or things like
this and so we can kind of build a more
human to human relationship a lot more
quickly we don't have to go through this
whole rigmarole of me basically showing
them oh no I understand you I can
actually understand you can actually
speak to me and them having to gauge
like does you really understand me or or
or like this like does he gonna know
this cultural reference and things like
that and so to that extent it's been
really useful and like a lot of the
times even in the United States if I go
and talk to a Japanese person on the
side of the road if I ask them about
something I'll like I'll just maybe be
like oh I liked your backpack where'd
you get it in Japanese and we can have a
little chitchat in japanese without
before it even gets to the point of like
wait why are why do you speak japanese
and a lot of times we'll be like are you
half japanese like did you did you like
live in japan or something and so we can
kind of actually build a relationship a
lot more quickly and I think that that's
the point and also I think that you know
when you talk to someone who has a very
thick accent it's not the most pleasant
thing and it can take a while to really
get used to it and get over it and so I
think it in a way it's just I'm almost
doing the Japanese people a favor by not
making them have to listen to a
butchered version of their language and
I think they appreciate that yes
absolutely
I think I think this this interviews got
to be long because I have a few no
actually have been ten questions I was
thinking why don't we break it down into
two parts we're gonna have you're gonna
this is gonna take probably two hours
well we could break it down into two
parts and then and then and then we can
make the outer interview maybe another
day or I think there's a thing so the
more the more stuff we delve into I
think we're on the same wavelength than
a lot of things so I'm just telling you
this because I have I don't know I have
16 more questions okay let's do it
so is there anything special about
Japanese that makes it more suited to an
immersion based approach or do you think
the method works equally well for all
languages
I definitely think that immersion works
equally well with any language but I
think the thing with Japanese is that
because it's so different from English
or other European languages if that's
where you're starting from it's more
necessary to use an immersion based
approach whereas for example if you're
alert an English speaker who's learning
Spanish you can get away with what I
would consider to be less inefficient
methods like just practicing thinking in
your native language and translating it
using grammar rules and practicing that
a lot you can get away with doing that
and have a pretty good result but in
Japanese that's it's not gonna work
because it's too different so that's why
I almost feel like learning a language
that was so difficult like Japanese
forced me to really hone in on what the
true principles of language acquisition
are and develop this method and I think
that you're gonna have it's even going
to be easier to feel the benefits of
immersion learning a language more
similar to your native language because
the process is going to play out a lot
more quickly like in if you combined
active study with a lot of immersion in
a language that's from the same language
family as your native language would say
probably in just a few months you're
gonna be able to build a really large
degree of comfort in that language and
my you know friend and business partner
yoga that was his experience with
Portuguese he first he learned Japanese
to a pretty high level of fluency and
then Chinese to a pretty high level of
fluency and then he he went to Brazil
and learned Portuguese and really
dedicated as much time as he could to
learning that language and he said that
he was speaking fluently in just three
months and all the Portuguese people
were totally blown away and that it was
a it was almost shocking because his
standards were built up through studying
Asian languages how long it takes to
build proficiency so yeah so this is
another I had looking for another
question here but I had another one in
my mind that I wanted to ask you oh yeah
that's that's what came to my mind I've
noticed that Japanese is a highly I
don't know if you can use this word in
English a situational language that is
it differently from other from other
European languages we're more or less we
know I don't know we just greet a person
I've never seen or I don't know somebody
comes to your place I've noticed that I
have a few
japanese friends that when they came
here and i lived some experiences
there's some things that are really
different just to give an example now do
you listening to me you don't do like
mmm all the time i just noticed that for
example on the phone i've seen i wasn't
it I was in Paris and I saw a Japanese
girl she was working there and she had
received a call from a client and she
was constantly doing mmm-hmm oh yeah
say all the time and I was talking to
this guy was in Brussels I was with my
friend of mine Luca who's the the the
friend I talked about who lived in Japan
for 10 years and this guy was listening
to me and all of a sudden he did this he
did like he closed his eyes and I said
me and I just turned to move and I just
fall asleep what I was talking well he
actually Luca explained to me he was
trying to you know pay that was a sign
where I'm really paying attention to
where you but not just that you know
just for example a Japanese friend of
mine she came and I was not supposed to
show the entire apartment because the
Japanese don't show you the entire
apartment they show you your room and I
was showing her so or I heard I don't
know if this is true that the Japanese
it makes total sense to me
but I don't like receiving gifts because
I don't know what to say if it the gift
of so I heard that some Europeans or
some Westerners in general they go who
live in Japan they go and visit some
Japanese friends and to bring a gift and
the first thing that the Japanese do is
take the gift and say hi and they put it
aside you know that so it's not just
that but I have noticed also in terms of
language it's the the language they use
the gestures they do it's everything is
very different you how can you so that
my question is okay you were in the
United States you let's suppose that
okay you went to Japan but let's suppose
what it was the advice or a piece of
advice you can give to a person an
American for example or in a time who is
not going to do to be in Japan for the
next say five years and it has to learn
from home how they learn this stuff you
know from home yeah yeah totally well
actually I spent I basically became
fluent in Japanese largely outside the
United States I've only spent six months
total in Japan and that was about six
months into my immersion learning and so
when I came back from Japan I had
year of immersion learning under my belt
and I still was not where I would
consider to be fluent and so it was
living in the United States that I
really got to the level that I am now
and I did that through using Japanese
media and Japanese YouTube and just the
Internet a lot and also making Japanese
friends here and I was lucky that when I
went to college there was a lot of
Japanese foreign exchange students who
had their own little Japanese community
that I was able to become a part of but
so I think that you can really learn a
lot just through watching movies and
dramas and and TV shows because you if
you watch a slice-of-life drama or like
a romance drama you're gonna see lots of
scenarios in daily life now of course
it's not necessarily a hundred percent
realistic there's gonna be a lot of
exaggerations or a lot of things that
don't actually happen in real life but
if you watch enough dramas you can kind
of see what are the common elements that
seem to be you see across other dramas
or even reading novels you see what are
the things that happen in novels and you
just start to pick up on these things
like you know how the way that you take
your shoes off when you first walk into
a house and how you turn them around so
that they face the door you put them
down it's like you just see that happen
so many times and ultimately I do think
that you're not gonna be able to pick up
on everything just through watching TV
shows essentially or even interacting
with Japanese people outside of Japan
because a lot of these very specific
cultural elements they only really exist
in Japan so you can't even necessarily
pick them up from a Japanese person
who's living in America because the
house the physical houses are different
the physical objects that we use to to
eat and clean and everything are
different but you can get pretty close
you can say maybe get on the culture
elements like 80% and if you go to Japan
and you're conversationally fluent in
Japanese and you know most of the
cultural customs you're gonna be able to
pick up on whatever you're missing
really quickly right because it's just
gonna be a matter of you go to eat maybe
you do something with your chopsticks
that's not rude and your Japanese
general bit that's actually like weird
you're not supposed to do that and then
you'll note and then you won't do it
again
so I think it's kind of like yeah if you
want to reach perfection you're gonna
have to live in that environment but you
can get to the point where you have
enough under your belt that picking up
whatever you're missing is gonna be
really quick and easy by the time you do
get to Japan fantastic fantastic answer
so I have one more question before we
close part one and then we're going to
delve to the technicals more technical
stuff into part two is that
every yeah I I can tell you're enjoying
this so in your QuickStart guide you
recommend starting to speak only after
reaching 80% comprehension level in a
language and this is quite different
from the usual advice which is to speak
won't meet maybe not the usual but you
get some advice saying speak as early as
possible and in your opinion what's the
biggest benefit of waiting to speak so
now yeah yeah so I mean the biggest
benefit is that you're gonna save
yourself from building bad habits in the
language that you're gonna have to go
back and fix later and it's basically
the philosophy that it's easier to build
a good habit the first time than to
build a bad habit and have to go back
and fix it just due to the way that our
brains work but another thing is that
basically like with Japanese it's just
so different that if you just start
speaking from from day one what that
actually means is that you're gonna be
thinking in English and using grant
grammar formulas and vocabulary that you
memorized to essentially solve a math
problem in your head and then speak that
out and you can have some success with
this process and you can practice and
get better at this process but
fundamentally this process is what I
would consider to be entirely different
than the process of learning to speak
naturally through acquiring a kind of
critical mass of input where you're
learning how to just manipulate it kind
of naturally so from the very first time
that I started speaking Japanese I
wasn't really thinking in English I was
just I mean I was still very bad at it
and I was very slow but I had I kind of
had absorbed enough Japanese in my head
where it was more like Japanese elements
were popping up the first time and I was
kind of struggling to fit them together
to say something but it wasn't
translation it was still kind of maybe
similar to what an infant would go
through when they first start learning
to speak it's it's still a kind of
sloppy process but it was my brain
learning to function in Japanese without
relying on English the first time and so
really that's why I think practicing
speaking from the beginning you're
you're not actually practicing the skill
that's going to lead you to actually
become able to speak fluent when you're
doing this other irrelevant ability that
kind of has a ceiling on how far it can
take you which is maybe like ordering at
a restaurant or doing a good self
introduction and things like that so
what I view is
a more straightforward path is just
focus on understanding the language
first because before you can understand
the language in a way you really have no
idea how that language functions right
like you can read in Japanese textbook
Oh
when Japanese people like meet for the
first time they say like oh how'd you my
mustache go oh my gosh mas or whatever
but but in a way that's indirect
knowledge you're just you read that in a
book but you don't really know if it's
true so you can try to replicate that
and maybe it'll go well but for me I
would never speak something I ideally to
to a native speaker unless I've heard
other native speakers use that same
phrase or the same word in multiple
contexts so I know for sure no Japanese
people actually do this it's not
secondhand knowledge its first knowledge
and so before you can understand the
language you have no first-hand
knowledge you have no idea what Japanese
people are actually doing you're just
taking the word of your textbook and so
that's why I think in a way it's almost
like being blind and trying to try to
draw like a self-portrait you really
you're just going off hearsay and then
you can mess up the portrait and then
try to get feedback of a sighted person
but if you just think about it you
really need to be able to see yourself
to get a good result and that's what I
consider understanding to be you have to
have kind of an intuition for the
language you have to know like when you
have two synonyms what's the difference
in emotionality of those two synonyms
you know what's the difference in nuance
and you can't really grasp that just
from reading about it so I think
ultimately my approach is you focus on
understanding and getting the language
into your head and once you have it into
your head you have a little bit of an
intuition then you can start actually
imitating what you've actually seen
native speakers do and also you'll be
able to do that process I talked about
earlier of kind of steering yourself in
the right direction because you'll have
a sense for when you messed up at least
to a certain degree and that this is
what will allow you to not make bad
habits because as soon as you make a
mistake you'll have that alarm bell go
off in your head there's like in our
native language right sometimes I forget
to put an S at the end of a something
that's plural I'm speaking but as soon
as I do it I cringe I'm like oh wow it's
gonna make me sound stupid and so it
doesn't become a habit so ideally you
get to that point in your in your target
language so that you can save yourself
all the bad habits that you would make
if you were just doing that thing I said
earlier of thinking in English and
translating okay fantastic so as I said
before this is I think we can end it
there part one and then we're going to
talk we're going to keep
talking about Japanese and language
learning in part 2 okay so some see you
in a bit
you